localization my name is having cars on
my laundry believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all of the
world's major problems so insulting on
your journey today I'm gonna share my
seven tips and tricks to help you get
more subscribers so one of the questions
I get asked a lot but you guys who watch
my new channel you've seen the growth
that I've had in the past couple years
in the past couple months especially as
well and you know how do I get more
subscribers how do I grow my channel how
do I get people interested in my content
and so then the issue is Hugh - Evan
weighing my seven tips to help you get
more subscribers
[Music]
tip number one is great content that you
love is a base you have a precursor that
you love most of the content that you
guys are putting out these every other
zone is actually not that good
my goal is on free content that I'm
deeply proud of that I want to show my
grandkids I want my grandkids to watch
this video if my grandkids wanted to
create any kind of social channel of
whatever is around when my grandkids are
also create content these guys are still
to the goal I want it I wasn't the one
should be really proud like this is a
great video looking what grandpa is
created right like I'm gonna have to
love your content and I think the
challenge is so many people are trying
to be everywhere you're trying to be
across all the different platforms and
this was open to everything really
poorly it's not about just promoting
whatever coupon code you have or
whatever launch product if people don't
care about your spam
think one valuable content think of the
livescribe to this channel why did you
subscribe you subscribe because
somewhere along the lines of video that
really
gee amazed you watch the couple of if
you watch my videos I can never die not
bad
I subscribed right so thinking about
that people who you subscribe to are you
creating that kind of content for your
work because the month watch videos that
you would subscribe to people watch
watch
instagram user earth people on twitter
if you want facebook that you follow
that you want to consume every day
they're proud of the work you put a lot
of love into it and are you creating
content at that love doesn't mean you
have to do what i do or do what anybody
else does but it's the same love the
love of love that i put in to making my
content a little cry that I have in my
content are you taking that same
approach and bringing that same level of
pride and love into what you're doing if
you do that and I think you need to
focus centered like what a hot forum and
make it awesome
instead of going everywhere then you'll
simply get might expect since original
is be consistent super important
especially with alou media you got a
good consistent citizen citizen tween is
everything in entrepreneurship you have
to be consistent because Nick actually
every bit too many people is a business
at the beginning as well I think one
video along and make a video then stop
and start and stop within a video week
and then stop we have this moment and if
you're not consistent like if you look
at my tracks on you cheese as in
decibels where you're on today it really
started off when I was doing one video
with me when it was fabric of the
building for everyone me today the
cheapening today that was really it's a
big moment then we contributed they now
the divet retooling 3 is not huge but we
still continue to do it
consistency you need to have consistent
content because you get dropped out so
easily and you create a storyline if you
want to see what you're doing that if
you're doing blogs and you're talking
about.we basis once it would happen
if you talk about your business and your
ideas they want to see textbook is the
continuation tell me what's happening
that they want to see it
if I just created one who is the content
every month I wouldn't have a big
general has a minute inscriber that
wouldn't have the big impact that I have
and so the water really has success you
have to commit especially with a huge
world I'm looking at at least a number
of videos a week I try to get to one
reading a day it's really important but
consistent consistent consistent content
and the business system see every day
doing something you can have as half an
hour a day just something to grow your
brain and create for your business tip
number three is understand the algorithm
every social media network has different
algorithms if those real important
understanding algorithm that you are
Blankman it's how you can win against
bigger guys if you don't have the
talents if you don't have the production
ability if you don't have the graphic
design or the camera or line there
anything else it's how you can need to
be the guide as people attending with
your yield and get more started because
you'll understand the algorithm so you
should come to algorithm and Facebook
has an algorithm and Twitter how to come
out with everybody has their own
algorithm a player is more based on the
different tools it's still a top braces
and hit talk to different keywords
expert has our algorithms not understand
how meiosis works so the outfit my name
is ends best is YouTube and it's where
has the most success where I spend the
most amount of time and so I tracked the
difference between
posting a video a week two video days to
get into Zeta 2 videos a day I can tell
you the human chat between a video week
to video today you'll see if you give
your production quality staple you pick
and drop in production quality a little
bit you'll still get way more power to
make way more
daily and weekly it's not out of opinion
the fact it happens it's my channel is
other channels this consistency one
media dated to be dissipated same thing
stop my opinion this data it works if
you need to do today and there's a
decent right even lower slightly lower
qualitative crap is not going to work
but even slightly lower quality
comparison one video a day you'll see
grow and it goes into 3 is under
considering and attract it I follow it I
know it a video that's that's one minute
long where is this 10 minutes long Tim
in the video will precious every time
even a five-minute bristles attendant
with the way expressive series it used
to be around for 5 minutes long and now
we're moving forward 9 10 11 12 of those
long because that led 2,000 works we
tack on voters clips that's the end of
it because it's going to double the
watch time on the video I mean double
the watch time if you get more human you
get more mutants you get more
subscribers right so understanding what
YouTube watch on top of making quality
content both can you link with a failing
quality content and just ignore the
algorithm
yes you can't what you're hurting
yourself you have to be so insanely good
that people to share it is explode to
just ignore the algorithm you're you're
creating with you know when hands I'm
205 it's doable but why would you watch
it whereas you can if you understand
yoga rhythm even have less talent and
win because you're playing to the system
and so whatever network you're trying to
play on understand the algorithm it's
not that sometimes hard to figure ever a
lot of people talking about it the case
of the 80% knowledge is to profess
within the days you understand 80% of
would need to know where I'm playing
that now a lot of time testing nobody
else is tested I'm talking the DC team
there's ever seen anybody doing what
we're doing
so nobody knows there is no big we're
trying to prove
but I'm planning the last 20% and
playing a lot by person rather things
that we're trying to my channel which
you don't need to do this a sir just
understanding the first 80% I'll take
you with data understand will already
put you ahead whilst your composition
understanding them sis number four for
collaborations five to fold one of the
fastest wins grow any business five
people who are already out of your
target market if I win work with them so
that your message convinced okay so my
youtube contact by February of circum
your target audience name simpler
audience and find a way to collaborate
work together and once I found the best
results with our ones that are
non-competitive and almost where it was
provide some value to them any number to
subscribe to them so if I look at in
YouTube world to my first figure YouTube
corporations was with Tim Schmoyer and
arabes and I had smaller channels and
both of them at the time and I was a
subscriber to them announcements to me
all the content factor the understanding
algorithm right I want to learn that
eighty percent flies and so what
everybody had it was commenting and I
knew about the most fans of them so when
I reach out to them say hey I see you're
doing this you talking to youtubers
either this perspective I think I could
help I think my material background I
think I have a message like to be useful
to you and for table done for many other
things that were standalone and then he
invited me to his YouTube mastermind
group that we did another twelve maybe
knows maybe sixteen me to the November
so a lot of confidence gives channels
that I'm in with Daryl did one video is
about public speaking how to get public
speaking games through YouTube the
filters that I've done share my
experience and so the easiest
colorations to make I find the ones when
you're already expanded the channel
you're already subscribe they're a means
you have some kind of live together to
like that person's dies for whatever
reason as opposed to cold out reaches
where you don't know anything about them
but if there's some ways you can add
value to their channel to their content
and they can promote it to their
audience that is an easy way to big
norman bull
[Music]
tip number five have a business ball you
got to figure out how to make money on
to this right you post all the time to
the social media you have to have a
business model around it that feeds the
system that feeds the content that
allows you to build a team when I
started off I hate mix I think making
content I hate investor anything with
money timing right keep spending money
laundry see mr. not figure out wait how
do I make money off of everything I'm
doing or the project is just a hobby or
the project size because I can't figure
out a business model around it so with
some networks is easier with YouTube
they have built-in advertisers you can
do that with brand deals if available
you can tell you emerge this products
the patreon now does exist is you can
have your fans help fund you a little
bit harder with the other platforms they
have such big amount of positions as
much yes it could be for your business
you know trying to then salsa as a
business is on social media we don't
care will make you money through the
videos or from Twitter or brand deals
about getting people to sign up for
salsa classes and take lessons with us
that's the main driver so whether you're
seller across the surface you know on
the outside world where they kind of
sell it to a specific demographic
whether you're doing - times and their
brand deals understanding what your
business model is and then driving
towards that to try to make some money
so you not to support yourself but build
a team there's so many changes with them
at the climber cause there's so many
youtubers with channels that are bigger
than mine that they're still doing
everything themselves and they can't
afford to have anybody on your team they
don't have a business model around just
try to drive use and make content which
is great and they love it but it's still
just a hobby for them they do the
business all around it and it was
shocking that people with millions of
subscribers still aren't making a
full-time income from it and can't
afford to hire somebody underneath them
depending the nation's ended a few
factors but
try to give to build a business model
around this so you can support yourself
answer to build a team to make your
content more value which leads to number
six which is bility you don't you want
to make consistent great quality awesome
content you need to build a team if it
recognizes what you're fantastic at
we're the best in the world
and then potentially best in the world
of not there yet and the surrounding
some of people who can do the rest
so for me editing is not what I'm
greatest you know for me being the
videographer is not what I'm greatest if
you go back to my videos to see that
they look worse than what they do right
now the camera or the editing is way
worse I'm way worse on center as well
but I chose to spend my time focusing on
being a better speaker and be better
over research to pick the clips that are
going to make it into the final review
you guys and everything else gets
assigned to the people on my team so
this is eight people who work on my
agency with different countries some
full-time basis someone a part-time
basis and that allows it make more
content how do you move from one video a
week to video is a to a day to three
days and you keep this assistant see up
in the quality level up team and so
that's when you get more subscribers and
if you start with just one project right
that's the very first person that I
hired for my business we just need one
collaboration videos together and that's
did well okay that's as well so the work
will be housed as soon as I dream under
my chin I poured it back into the
business to bring on my team so I can
build up so you want to start I'm what
are the things you hate the most in your
business and you need to learn your
social media if it's a graphic design
and it is instilling the research
whatever we hate the most
some people love me UNITA Tennessee
didn't want to be in frustration go far
but if you have to be paid right like
there's some people if you plus editing
this people who love being for the
camera and they're looking for
experience in front of the camera go
work with them you don't receive them of
the stutter practice build up your
portfolio get your experience get better
build up content that brings a little
bit of money and then you can afford
that a budget that going higher and this
number seven is model success and I love
this is always one of my goes to your
turn if your growth what you should be
doing in a new market one of the factors
wizards do is look at what you're
currently doing and learn doesn't you
copy them you could learn a lot on my
channel if you try to just copy me
you're never going to have massive
success just in Evin junior you can
learn some of the things that I'm doing
and apply to your channel you can also
learn from other industries and bring
them to your business so you'll either
learn the lot for my channel from guys
like their leaves from guys like Tim
Schmoyer from guys like you tonight
second best experience I guess I learned
from see Google done a lot more in the
luggage through my channel that was
grown to be bigger than their chests I'm
working them and I keep learning for
more people to make myself better I
learned from outside the industry from
the business world to say hey I think
it's important that is when he gets a
reply in her comment so I'm going to
hire a team of people to help me do that
remote reaches creators can't keep up
with the comments until it just leave
ended response or 20 minutes after video
and then the fits are gone I'm going to
give her slots and build up the team
that just comes from business bro
because look at Logan palms except that
he's had his YouTube channel where the
fastest project in terms of all time
became from the Bible and has this sense
really quick down YouTube implementing
the strategies work for him
in five six second videos apply this to
YouTube and really capturing people of a
short attention spans
and they type all the content around
them on this blog those two learn both
people insiders industries when you look
up some kind of logic that as well as
people from outside the industry say huh
I bring this something that doesn't
exist that hasn't been done before I'm
afraid and see if it works try to test
it doesn't work you can drop it what it
does you're running so that's my take on
a seven tips and tricks that cool to get
more subscribers I mean the suit has
moved into ass with you so there is a
topic you're going to cover in a future
seven ways check out the links in the
description you can go and cast your
vote also look for what the business
videos and you like it which tick was
your favorite from one of the seven is
there retention if I missed it you want
to ask the list leave it down below I'm
really here to find out with you guys
today I also want to give a good revenue
side sealed by Giuliana thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
through one word taking a picture and
sharing it really appreciate you for it
and I hope you enjoy doing so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you OPP need to believe with yourself
anyone ever 301 where it is club